سنرافق اليوم السيده بوسنيه هنا في
سراييفو لنتعرف عن قرب على طريقه شراء
مكونات وجبه افطار شهر رمضان وطرق تحضيرها
في مدينه اغلب سكانها مسلمون يمارسون
عباداتهم منذ قرون بالرغم من الحروب التي
عصفت بها خصوصا خلال ما عرف بحصار سرايفو
الذي استمر لاكثر من اربع سنوات مع
التذكير بان شراره الحرب العالميه الاولى
انطلقت من هنا من سرق ايفو في الثامن
والعشرين من يونيو حزيران
1914 بعد اختيار ولي عهد النمسا انذاك هيا
بنا
[موسيقى]
كما كل يوم في شهر رمضان الكريم تقوم
بليما البوسنيه ابنه السبعه والخمسين عاما
بالانطلاق من منزلها في ازقه سرايفو لشراء
مكونات وجبه عائلتها الرمضانيه تقصد السوق
الشعبي لكنها خلال دخوله تتوقف امام نصب
تذكاري لضحايا قذيفه سقطت في فبراير من
عام
وادت الى قتل 68 بوزنيا تقوم بقراءه
الفاتحه على ارواح الضحايا ومن ثم تواصل
شراء الخضار والبقوليات والفاكهه وكذلك
اللحوم والبيضه والالبان
[موسيقى]
اسكن مدينه سراييفو مع عائله وامي لدي
ثلاثه ابناء اثنان منهم ولدات بان الحرب
وامي شهدت حربين في البوسنه لكننا نرى في
بلدنا المستقبل الجميل واريد ان تبقى
عائلتي هنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد العوده من تسوقها تستقبل والده بيليما
البالغه واحده وتسعين عاما ابنتها برفقه
احفادها عدي وزيد ويهرع الجميع لتحضير
اطباق الافطار البوسنيه قبل ساعتين ونصف
الساعه من موعد الافطار التوبه وهو طبق
بسدي تقليدي يطهى فقط في شهر رمضان طبق
مكون من الالبان والبيض وكذلك الفلفل
المحشي واطباق بوسنيه ورمضانيه عائليه
[موسيقى]
انا سعيده لتحضير وجبه الافطار لافراد
عائله اليوم وانا اقوم بطهي اطباق رمضانيه
للاطفال والكبار في رمضان نقدم طبقه طوب
البوسني التقليدي تربيه اطفالنا على الدين
الاسلامي منذ نعومه اظافرهم امر اساسي في
طاعه الله هكذا صرفينا وسننربي اجيالنا
القادمه كمسلمين في اوروبا
ليث العربيه
البوسنه والهرسك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات